muy seguramente para dar va a ser la
figura clave en el gobierno porque
además es la figura fundamental de la
relación con la agencia de inteligencia
militar de pakistán el isi que es
finalmente el creador de los talibanes
en 1994 fue el conductor militar de los
talibanes en esa primera etapa de
gobierno hasta el inicio de la guerra
con los eeuu y fue quien además iguacú a
la cúpula talibán incluido osama
bin-laden del territorio de afganistán
en ese momento como ya hoy se sabe está
ampliamente documentado y desde 2003
baradar estuvo desde desde el principio
al lado del mulá omar hasta 2013 en la
confección de toda esta reconstrucción
de los talibanes y obviamente era esta
voz de alguna manera escondida o esta
voz que no era visible no tenía cara
durante todo este tiempo pero que era
finalmente la figura fundamental el otro
el que hemos visto con claridad es el
vocero jay la exijan que se quizás el
mayor es mucho más que un portavoz es
una especie de ideólogo clave y un
ideólogo moderado contemporáneo
aparentemente pero moderado dentro de
los términos de esa versión que los
afganos tienen de la ley islámica aquí
irán desplegando otros nombres distintos
que apenas empezamos a conocer con algún
detalle y aún digamos está por verse
cuáles van a ser realmente los que armen
la gran sura de afganistán que será en
última salud el gran consejo islámico y
que tendrá el papel tanto jurídico como
político y militar para tomar las
últimas decisiones dentro del nuevo
emirato islámico de afganistán hablemos
ahora de ese tipo de moderación es que
usted estaba comentamos porque
comentando porque hemos visto que los
insurgentes ahora con el control del
país están enviando al mundo un mensaje
conciliador y de respeto por los
derechos y las libertades pero puertas
adentro vemos represión asesinatos y
persecución y es apenas el comienzo como
será la relación del talibán con el ple
más internacional
realmente yo pues soy muy pesimista creo
que la mayoría de los observadores los
cautos son profundamente pesimistas en
este supuesto mensaje de moderación
realmente el mensaje de moderación para
poner un ejemplo en el caso de las
mujeres y aquí hay que poner el ejemplo
además que es esta presentadora de la
cadena de noticias todo lo de la prensa
de noticias a quien se le apareció un
talibán el lunes en la noche en su
programa de noticias y ayer mostraba
ella en su programa en su cuenta de
twitter que había quedado prácticamente
sin trabajo que quedaba prohibido volver
a aparecer en la televisión y que
incluso temía por su vida esto es la
demostración de lo que en últimas cuando
uno lee ya la vez término de lo que
estaban diciendo es las mujeres tendrán
derecho a educarse y aportar el 'burka'
dentro de ley islámica es decir no
exacto digamos una limitación muy fuerte
de la moderación es si profesor pero es
que seguimos hablando de las mujeres y
ésta sería ya mi última pregunta porque
el talibán habla de un gobierno
inclusivo sobre todo con las mujeres es
que tan real puede ser esto vamos a ver
a las mujeres dentro de la cúpula de la
cúpula gobernante fue simplemente una
frase cuando retomaron el poder
para mí es puro maquillaje aquí no va a
haber ninguna moderación no habrá este
asunto ya hemos visto también que por
ejemplo desde antier hay una persecución
de los colaboradores de la otan de los
estados occidentales casa por casa sitio
por sitio y hay un intento de
prácticamente volver a las viejas
prácticas el amo del supuesto discurso
moderado es paciente para presentarse en
el mundo pero no es algo efectivo ni que
sea real y creíble y obviamente la mayor
preocupación de la reincorporación del
estado islámico desde como este grupo
permita sunita y obviamente esto va a
marcar una limitación muy fuerte frente
a ese mensaje